انا من بيروت العميد الياس حناء الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك العميد
الياس عن دخول دبابات ابرامز في طبيعه
المعارك وما قد تحدثه من اثر في طبيعه
المعارك وتطورها
عبد القادر يعني وحده وثلاثين دبابه
ابرامز حسب بوليتيكو مركز او منصه هناك ما
يقارب عشره او 12 دبابه هذا يدل انها سريه
بسيطه هي لن تغير في المعادلات الاساسيه
هذه دبابه معقده تقنيا حتى في الرمايه حتى
في الذخيره الايرانيم المنظم انا اعتقد
انها اول مرحله هي رفع معنوي مهم للقوات
الاوكرانيه وكانها في مرحله تشكيل
الاحتياط العملاني لو في حال تم خرق فعلا
الخط الثالث في روبوتين وما شابه او حتى
توكماك قد تكون هذه الدبابات هي الاساسيه
للمتابعه الخرق والمناوره في خلفيه الجيش
الاوكراني لن يكون لها تاثير مباشر حاليا
هي بعيده عن المعركه من تدرب عليها ليس في
واقع وعي الزمان والمكان لمراحل القتال
الاوكرانيه
عميد الياس حنا تحدث بالاضافه الى قرب
وصول دبابات ابرامز على استمرار بلاده في
الحصول على القدرات العسكريه الضروريه كما
قال بما فيها طائرات الاف سته عشر كيف
تراقب تطور هذا الحصول الاوكراني على هذه
المعدات العسكريه من الغرب منذ بدايه
الحرب الى الان
مريم النمط الذي تعودناه انه دائما
اوكرانيا تطلب يتاخر الغرب وتاتي هذه
المعطيات الغرب يعتمد استراتيجيه او
مقاربه الحاجه الميدانيه التي يتطلبها ارض
المعركه من ثم ياتي هذا السلاح يعني
بالطبع الاف 16 هي عامل مهم جدا اساسي
ولكن العدد الاتي قد لا يوازي العدد
المتوفر لدى روسيا ما يقارب 900 الطائره
اغلبها من الجيل الرابع ولكنها عنصر اساسي
يعني بدل ان يطلق الستور مشادو من طائره
روسيه قديمه يطلق من الاف 16 وهذا امر
يتعلق بامكانيه دمج الاف 16 بالعمليات
العسكريه الاساسيه وهذا امر عاده في
الحروب يتطلب وقت يتطلب تجربه يتطلب دروس
مشتقات وقد لا تاتي في المرحله القريبه
مريم ملف 16 هل معنى ذلك ان ما يجري حتى
الان العميد الياس حنان يقول بان ستكون
طويله بعيده المدى اليس بامكان من يدعمون
اوكرانيا ان يقدموا اسلحه حتى يتم الحسم
سريعا
ليس هناك من حسم سريع عبد القادر الرئيس
الروسي اجتمع بالرئيس الكوري يطلب مزيد من
السلاح مزيد من الذخيره وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تحضر لتاليف جيش جديد وحتى
استدعاء للخدمه العسكريه هو ياخذ من ايران
المسيرات فاذا الكل يحذر الحرب الطويله
وهذا الامر ايضا تحضر له اوكرانيا من جهه
اخرى من هنا قول رئيس الاركان الامريكي ان
لدى اوكرانيا نافذه تقدر بسته اسابيع
معينه قبل بدء الشتاء ولكن يرد الاوكراني
ليقول ان خلال مرحله الشتاء سنتابع الحرب
ولكن ليس بطريقه سريعه الامر طويل جدا عبد
القادر شكرا لك من بيروت العميد الياس
حناء الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي